and in a little bit less than two weeks
all nevadans aged 16 and up can get the
copic 19 vaccine
and just yesterday those with underlying
conditions became eligible
but experts say a lot of people still
aren't signing up and they're worried
that trend is going to continue
arco mana joining us now live tonight
from the convention center
with their plea to the public orco
well denise a spokesperson for the
southern nevada health district tells me
it's mega sites at the cashman center
and here at the convention center are
not operating at full capacity right now
that's what some other clinics around
town are seeing too so they're
encouraging
everyone who's eligible to get
vaccinated now
we want to be busy dr michael gardner is
in charge of the unlv covet 19
vaccination clinics and says despite
expanded eligibility across nevada
several appointments are still available
we're doing
eleven twelve hundred a day we're
designed to do over two thousand a day
we can ramp up dr gardner says vaccine
hesitancy is partially to blame but he
wants everyone to know it's safe and
effective the question now is what will
happen on april 5th when all nevadans
age 16 and older are able to get the
shot
our biggest fear is that we won't
have a huge influx he's encouraging
everyone to get vaccinated
i'm hoping that the vast majority of the
population
will make that clear choice we had about
150 no-shows
dr christina madison who runs the
roseman university vaccine clinic
says some people are not coming back for
their second dose because of
transportation or mobility issues that's
why they'll continue focusing on
targeted outreach for vulnerable and
minority communities when the 16 plus
eligibility begins
we already have three strike teams
scheduled for that week
we want to make sure that everyone has
access and
not that we're just getting the vaccine
out quickly but we're getting the
vaccine out equitably
the goal is to move past this pandemic
the way we can move forward is through
the vaccine
the southern nevada health district also
tells me they are prepared to increase
hours at their various sites to offer
more appointments as vaccine eligibility
expands on april 5th reporting live from
the las vegas convention center tonight
workout mana 8 news now